uh i take uh
anywhere between six to eight showers a
day it's all about a fresh start
most of the time writing is spent not
writing
so if something if you see something you
don't like it it's not working figure
out why
if you see something and you do like it
and it's working figure out why rather
than
kind of tell the audience uh who a
character is i like to show the audience
what a character wants you mentioned
the rules there are rules uh they were
written over 2 000 years ago
by aristotle in a short book called the
poetics
the rules of drama are older than
christianity uh
and a a young writer would do well to
learn those rules did you develop or
find
the aaron sirkin voice i mean that is
that something you're even aware of or
even think about
um it's uh what i'm what i'm aware of
is is sticking to my own voice
i i learn a lot from other writers i'm
very easily influenced
by other writers and and i try to be
influenced by the good ones
uh more than the not so good ones but
you can be influenced by the not so good
ones too in a bad way
uh um and i'll always
i always when i'm starting something i
feel like
i need to start it in somebody else's
voice for instance with the social
network
uh when i began writing i was very aware
that i was writing
for characters these were the youngest
characters that uh that i had ever
written for
uh they they alternate between 19 and
then
uh 25 years old in the movie and that i
uh that i needed to sound youthful
somehow that and
more than that i needed to you know it
was taking place in the 21st century
uh and i'm just not somebody who's in
the 21st century so
so that i needed to skateboard it up or
mountain dew it up
or somehow and there are two things
about that that are crazy or i should
say at least two things about that are
that are crazy i'm sure that anyone
listening to this can can count more
than that
uh one is not all 19 year olds
speak alike that's it that's that's not
a language uh
and the other is uh i'm terrible when
uh when i'm trying to write like
somebody else so
i tried about a page and a half of that
pulled my head off my torso
uh and put it back on and just said
you you can't write like anybody but
yourself
i'm a great audience member i uh uh
when when i come into a movie theater
when i come into a theater to see a play
when i turn on the television set
uh i i'm the best audience member you
could ask for you can show me a magic
trick
50 times uh and i'll still be amazed by
it
but what i do do and what i would
recommend to you were talking about
young writers before
is be a student uh
as well have a good time watching the
movie the first time or the second time
the third of the fourth or fifth but at
some point
be a diagnostician if if you don't like
the movie if the movie isn't working
don't just shrug it off and say well
these guys uh they made a chunky movie
figure out why
uh what went wrong in there so if
something if you see something you don't
like it it's not working
figure out why if you see something and
you do like it
and it's working figure out why um
figure out how the magic trick uh is
done to go back to that metaphor
and then go back to enjoying the magic
trick we're going to talk
about character and hopefully mostly how
aaron develops character
so i'm just going to the first question
is just walk me through pick a character
do you do you write like a short story
about them do you write prose about them
before you do dialogue
do they come from real people how does a
character actually come about
in your mind i don't do those things uh
that you just mentioned other people do
and uh
it's important to note that there is no
one way to do it everybody
uh does it differently for me uh
rather than kind of tell the audience uh
uh who a character is i like to show the
audience
what a character wants uh uh and it all
boils down to
intention and obstacle somebody wants
something something standing in their
way of getting it
uh it they they want the girl they want
the money they want to get to
philadelphia
uh uh it doesn't matter but they have to
want it bad if they can need it
uh that's even better something
formidable uh is standing in their way
and the tactics that that
character uses uh to overcome the
obstacle is going to define
uh uh who the character is it's it's
like having a christmas tree and then
hanging around
uh you write some just incredible
dialogue uh
what is your secret so i can let other
writers know
uh and make other people's scripts
better
well thank you um and i i would tell
those writers to
uh to write in their voice uh to
uh uh to not try to write the way
someone else writes
uh there's nothing wrong with you know i
i try to let
sort of david mamet get into my
bloodstream uh i i try to let tom
stoppard get into my bloodstream
um any number of writers who
i revere uh but i can tell you that when
i'm writing
i am talking out loud i'm playing all
the parts uh in my head
and uh one of the things i think that
helps with
is you are less likely to write a line
of dialogue that's
unspeakable um uh you know you're
i love you my dear like the stars love
the
you know it once you have to say it out
loud uh
you'll get the message that you can't
ask an actor to try to
you know casualize that line frankly the
best career advice i've ever
gotten was probably go for god's sake
don't try to be a professional rider
you'll starve to death uh i i couldn't
follow that advice because i so
badly wanted to be a professional writer
uh but it uh
it was practice uh that writing is
like playing the violin uh it takes
practice you get better
as you get older uh and
uh you just um don't get beaten down by
rejection when people are talking about
something
uh it isn't so much their position that
i'm trying to imitate
as the as the way they're presenting it
i'm just trying to phonetically recreate
the sound of political sophistication
and
uh and and knowing what you're talking
about and oftentimes in in things that
i've written
um whether it's a few good manner i
wrote a movie called malice or the
american president
uh or sports night or the west wing uh
there'll be a quick passage uh uh
that'll go by and
you know somebody the studio a producer
someone will say you know gee no one's
gonna know
uh what these two people are talking
about you know i'll say it's actually
not important that they do what's
important is that the audience say wow
these guys really know what they're
talking about
uh that's interesting and that's what i
try to do well at first
all i knew was what i didn't want to do
and what i didn't want to do was a
conventional biography
uh what we call a biopic a biographical
picture
uh which is a cradle to grave structure
it's a structure that audiences are very
familiar with
this happened and this happened and this
happened and this happened then he went
to the doctor and then he died
uh uh so i knew what i didn't want to do
so
while trying to think of what i did want
to do i just started the
research process i started talking to
all the real life people who are
represented in the film and a few dozen
others i began to identify points of
friction between steve and steve wozniak
between steve
and his daughter lisa between steve and
john scully and so on
and i like claustrophobic spaces
i like compressed periods of time where
there's a clock ticking
uh and i thought maybe i can dramatize
all these conflicts
uh in three real-time
scenes real time is when 30 minutes for
you and the audience is the same as 30
minutes for a character on screen
uh and i could have them all take place
backstage
in the minutes leading up to one of his
fame famous product launches
it was a radical departure from a normal
structure
uh i went to the studio and got their
permission to do it that's something i
wouldn't ordinarily do
uh and what i knew for sure is that it
would
this was going to be a movie built
entirely out of words so you were going
to need a visual
master like danny boyle uh to give it
any kind of visual interest
and of course you are going to need a
world-class cast of actors aaron could
you talk to us about your writing style
i know dan brown
talks about it he does jumping jacks
before he writes books
and uh walt is a morning writer and i
write at night
what is your style when you set down is
there some traditional thing that you
always do
dan brown's good i'm going to start
doing jumping jacks now i didn't know
that he could get the blood flowing
isn't it he said
i drive around a lot i mean i have to
you have to think of what you're gonna
write before you write it and i drive
around i listen to music
music usually will uh start something
going
um and then i i talk out loud to myself
i get into arguments uh
uh in the car if you were stopped next
to me at a red light you'd think i was a
crazy person
um uh and then when i have it i uh i
start writing
cool so any particular kind of music for
writers like me who want
more inspiration who want to write great
scripts or uh
it's usually uh my taste in music
stopped maturing once i graduated from
high school so
uh it's music i listen to in high school
so sometimes
i'll stick in a c cd or sometimes it'll
just be potluck i'll turn on the radio
and hopefully just stumble across a song
maybe a song i've never heard before
um and you know i'll want that song to
serve his score for a scene so i'll
literally start with the score and think
of trying to think of a scene
you know that that'll go with that
uh i take uh anywhere between six to
eight
showers a day um uh because i'm not i'm
not
exaggerating i'm not exaggerating i'm
not a germaphobe it has nothing to do
with germs it's all about a fresh start
uh okay i was writing i was writing was
not going well i'm i'm writing badly
start again
take a shower put on different clothes
and you'll feel refreshed and start
again is it harder sober is it better
sober i don't care if it's harder uh
or better sober i i i should be
dead seven times uh uh by now and
um i'm i'm so glad i'm not yeah maybe
um uh it would be easier uh uh to write
with coke maybe i'd write better
uh with coke but i'm and there's
writing well is so important to me um
that there's no advantage uh i wouldn't
give myself
except that what was the first story you
ever wrote
you know i never wrote for pleasure
until right after i got out of college
until then writing for me was a chore to
be gotten through
for a school assignment i moved to new
york to
begin my life as a as a struggling
actor which is what i thought i was i
had studied
acting uh my whole life
i was sharing this very tiny studio
apartment with my
ex-girlfriend and i don't mean that
she's now my ex-girlfriend she's my
ex-girlfriend then when i was living
with her
and she was dating my best friend
one weekend she was
out of town doing the she played
strawberry shortcake
so my ex-girlfriend went out on the
strawberry shortcake tour
uh this was a friday night in new york
that anyone who lives in a big city
whether it's new york toronto or any
place else
you've had this night it feels like
everyone you know has been invited to a
party that you haven't been invited to
ev everyone's gone for some reason
nothing in the in this little studio
apartment that worked on electricity was
working like the television
wasn't working the stereo wasn't working
this was
about a year or about a year before
apple introduced
this thing called the macintosh so there
wasn't one of those but what there was
was a high school friend of mine uh who
was a struggling journalist
had on that friday with him his
grandfather's
semi-automatic typewriter this is a
typewriter with electric
keys but a manual return he was going
out of town for the weekend with
his girlfriend uh i didn't want to
schlep it around with him so he asked me
if i could hang on to this
typewriter for him so i said sure so
i'm in the studio apartment no friends
around the tv isn't working the stereo
isn't working there's no such thing
as the internet
[Music]
for the story to really work i guess i
had to have to say there's no such thing
as books yet
either those hadn't been invented but
uh and i didn't have three dollars in my
pocket what i had
was my friend's grandfather's
semi-automatic typewriter which also had
paper in it so the only way for me to
entertain myself was to stick a piece of
paper
in this typewriter and i did what i'd
never done before which was that i wrote
in
dialogue and uh and i started writing in
dialogue and i stayed up
all night um uh writing i i
it was that was the moment that i fell
in love with the sound of my own voice
uh and started writing all night and
felt a
confidence doing it that i'd actually
never felt with
acting even though i was a pretty cocky
actor um
and uh but you know that morning it
invited a couple of friends over
and you know said you know read this out
loud for me and they
were very encouraging about it and
that's the first story i ever wrote
[Music]
you